yeah was he intense with you did he want
did he was he intense as a director
because he wanted you to feel that or
not at all no he spoke very little
didn't talk about story didn't talk
about acting didn't talk about the scene
never nothing ever ever ever how
many the most I did was nine and that
was for the blanket party when they put
the soap in the towels and beat me up we
did nine of those the big scene the big
famous
scene um
they say the big famous scene anyway
it's it's uh um you know when I kill the
drill instructor and I shoot myself that
that we did three times you know and
then we did a an effect for the blood in
the wall and that was it what I mean all
you hear is 100 takes 90 takes 50 doors
I'm not saying he didn't do that with
other people but not with us not with
Matthew and I and um and and Arles like
we
never Matthew Matthew arus and and in
their team when they were doing the
Vietnam stuff they got stuck behind that
wall there's a wall that they're behind
before they go into the village right at
the end when the sniper gets right at
the end of the first act when the sniper
uh second act when the sniper gets
killed remember all those guys get shot
in that one little areir they were
behind that wall for I believe around
four
months
so and it was merely because of the way
Stanley made movies you know he was very
different than anybody I've ever worked
with before you know he if he if the
light wasn't right if the if if the if
the scene was flat he he wouldn't shoot
he just wouldn't shoot did you ever see
him angry not like like you mean like
screaming and yelling and stuff no
because you see it again in The Shining
in the document you see it damn it shell
you knew it was there oh come on yeah
well they had a particular yeah relation
yeah some people say it was deliberate
on his behalf because he wanted her to
you know but I don't know if that's true
I don't know what it was but it was
pretty you know pretty devastating for
everybody